I wanted to ask you what advice you
maybe have for entrepreneurs that are
just about a year and a half into their
journey but I feel like everything you
just said is perfect just believing in
yourself having faith just grinding out
doing the work and eventually success
will come is there anything else that
you want to add yeah I wouldn't I like I
would stop comparing yourself like who
cares of you year and a half day maybe
you're ten years and you know like just
if you like what you're doing you you
have a passion for it you have to find a
way to keep going absolutely and what
I'm looking so like I'll look up the
people right like I'm not the greatest
speaker in the world you know I love
length brown how do you guys know les
brown I know who let's round it is young
les brown that guy is sick and i don't
want to be young Les Brown got like
young Les Brown speaking videos it's
crazy I'm nowhere close to young Les
Brown but I'm not like so what like so
what that I'm not close it gets an
aspiration to me like people chase
perfection and they get pissed when it
when they don't hit their goal it's not
about the goals about doing the work to
get better and I think just continually
like hard work is just I guess in me
when I talked about my agent when I
joined the agency I was the worst one at
the agency like my agency was like you
know what I don't know if I want to take
you on man i don't know if i wanted to
as a client like everybody else who has
been with him they were more polished
speakers than i was and it then i
understand i looked back at my videos
like I actually really sucked i thought
it was hot stuff but I really sucked and
then he said but you know I'm okay we'll
take a flyer like you are your are near
our flyer for the year we'll see what
happened and then I just worked harder
than everybody else when they were
having a hard time but he asked me to do
my story one of the first exercises make
your story so I would make a video but
my story but 15 minute video he would
review it I makes it amor you can review
it give me feedback afternoon I do it
again another 15 minutes right here is
you it gets beep
and do it again at night like three
three four times a day if he's making it
i did that intro story 40 times for him
and he gave me feedback I would make
videos every day when the other people
at the agency complained about not
having time during the week to make one
video counselors life and so I within a
couple months I became the best practice
example to like you guys should be doing
Evans doing I was the worst eli just
listen to their advice and grinded and i
became the best practice so it's like
it's not for me to say i'm a genius i'm
special like it's the opposite i'm not
special i'm super ordinary introverted
don't have the skills and i just worked
hard I've done four thousand videos on
my youtube channel some of them are
unlisted our practice because I look for
that you better get better as a shot
right like you have to happy a new level
of garbage and not improve representing
four thousand times yeah right so I
think people put too much pressure on
themselves to be good at the start you
see maybe you see a gary video you see
somebody like crushing it hard and you
go and try to do it and your thing sucks
like you suck at the start and the hard
part is you have taste but you don't
have the skill like you know what's good
you know what a good jump shot looks
like which can't do it and so when you
get out there and you know that you
thought you quit and so whatever you're
making you know what will look good you
have certain standards for quality and
then when you can't go out and make that
immediately you quit and so it's good to
have those standards it's good to have
like the MJ jump shot as the thing to
aspire to but understand that you're
going to suck you're going to fall
you're not going to get anything the
first time and just make everything
better everything better like maybe you
guys look at your show like hey we love
the breakfast club you know Charlamagne
and what do you know like oh good this
race is it's a good show man like i was
doing and asking about I feel like
Charlemagne is my spirit animal an
immaculate
okay like okay it's a good show tomorrow
right dude that's awesome have guests
coming great you know but it takes time
to be that good right because I'm kind
of practice in and so it's like that's
the ideal here's where we are and just
every show needs to be better like I
serve you whoever you bring on neck that
show it has to be better than that as
incremental show let's say and just keep
building their way up and you get to be
at a higher level so am I think it's
hard when people see that they don't
have they know it looks good and they
can't do it and they just quit too soon
thank you guys so much for watching
thank you to the guide some v and our
media for the awesome interview the full
link is in the description below if you
want to check it out I love to know what
did you think what are your thoughts
leave them in the comments below I'm
super curious to find out finally I want
to give a quick charter to Camille
Kubiak thank you so much Camille for
picking up a copy of my book your one
word it really really really means a lot
to me and I hope you're enjoying the
reason thank you guys again for watching
I believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one where it is that's love